beaucoup pour la fermeture tu es prêt
et à 12h57 donc du coup de Fleury à
Benoît
vous êtes donc au sein d'une agence de
conduite régionale il en existe 28 en
France ça représente à peu près 500
salariés qui se relaient 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7 donc chacun des
chargées de conduite est équipé comme ça
de 6 écrans d'ordinateurs qui lui permet
de surveiller et d'agir également à
distance sur l'ensemble du réseau
électrique sur le territoire français
et tu pourras mettre à 13h03 donc là
j'ai un collègue qui vient de m'appeler
il travaille sur le réseau 20000 volts
il a besoin de moi pour enfin du service
de la serre pour couper le courant sur
la ligne donc il a besoin il suffit bien
le RSR du tronçon HTA en aval de la
troisième pic inter ac3t au centre
donc là vous êtes sur la zone la plus
sensible au sein d'une agence de
conduite régionale ce qu'on appelle la
salle des machines donc c'est dans cette
salle des machines qu'on va retrouver
tout ce qui permet de piloter à distance
notre réseau électrique avec tous les
automatismes qui s'y trouvent
donc là dans illustrer ce qui se
passerait en cas de délessage en fait en
cas de lissage on va commencer en fait
par couper certaines lignes électriques
mais pas toutes donc là on voit bien
qu'en fait ce réseau là il leur tension
et puis en fait on a une autre ligne
électrique qui est le reste sous tension
et puis une fois qu'il y aura deux
heures qui se seront écoulées en fait on
va rétablir les clients qui ont subi
cette première coupure et en fait ce
sont c'est une autre ligne électrique
qui va être impactée par le délestage
vous avez ici plusieurs départs
en cas d'éco-atte rouge on va délester
un des départs un ou plusieurs départs
qui va alimenter soit un quartier soit
une commune donc on part de la
production de la production on passe par
le réseau RTE transport on arrive chez
enedis chez nedis premier échovoit rouge
on va abaisser la tension 20.000 volts
19000 volts puis après on revient sur
nos départs 20.000 volts qui seront
impactés par un délestage si
l'abaissement de la tension ne suffit
pas
[Applaudissements]
ici vous avez le réseau 20000 volts qui
va qui part alimenter les différentes
communes pour aller au plus près des
clients